ça c'est la courbe qu'on ne veut pas
voir trop de cas trop vite
les hôpitaux sont surchargés et plus de
malades vont mourir de lakovic 19 ce
qu'on veut c'est aplatir la courbe
c'est à dire prendre des mesures qui
vont ralentir la contagion et l'étaler
dans le temps parce qu'on sait
maintenant qu'on ne pourra pas arrêter
la pandémie on ne pourra que la ralentir
il faut absolument aplatir la courbe
l'arrivée du virus équin temps sic les
coronavirus leur principal réservoir et
modes de transmission c'est souvent les
enfants en bas âge
il faut fermer rapidement les garderies
les écoles primaires surtout parce que
c'est cela qui sont les principaux
réservoirs la mauvaise courbe c'est la
chine et l'italie est probablement
l'iran les autorités se sont attaqués à
l'épidémie trop tard et leurs services
de santé ont été débordés par rapport au
modèle italien de ce qu'ils ont observé
mais ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
probablement agir d'ici une semaine dix
jours au plus l'exemple à suivre est
celui de la corée du sud qui avec 7800
cas n'a eu que 66 morts
proportionnellement quatre fois moins
que la chine est huit fois moins que
l'italie
les coréens vont à la recherche des cas
possibles
il est est systématiquement et
massivement à domicile et même avec
service à l'auto les endroits suspects
sont soigneusement désaffectée et
surtout les autorités encouragent ce
qu'on pourrait appeler l'éloignement
sociale
pas n'importe où quarantaine dans les
régions où les cas ont été détectés plus
grand rassemblement institution fermée
et contacts limités entre individus le
tout dans la plus grande transparence
avec déluge d'informations plus des
mesures pour atténuer l'impact
économique d isolement
si on veut vraiment être actif on va
choisir la zone où il ya une
transmission et on va fermer dans ces
zones là mais si on pense que la zone
s'étend à la province en entier mais il
faudra le faire dans un de façon
générale tout en même temps parce que on
parle de fermeture un général pour
contrôler les coronavirus sur des
périodes de quatre à huit semaines est
beaucoup plus près de huit semaines des
experts recommandent l'éloignement
sociale bien avant de parvenir à une
contamination de 1% de la population
le canada n'y est pas moins de cent cas
sur une population de 37 millions
d'habitants il reste de la marge
cela s'applique bien sûr au niveau de la
province la ville où la localité
jean-michel le prince ray du canada à
montréal